Most writers use their note-taking
software as a filing cabinet, but this
system turns it into a windmill. So,
today, I'm going to teach you an
unconventional system for nonfiction
writing that'll help you transform notes
into manuscripts. This is a system that
gets smarter every time you use it. One
where your ideas churn, connect, and
develop on their own, and one that
outputs valuable writing almost
automatically. This only became possible
when I learned how to integrate AI into
my second brain the right way. So, let's
start with the goal. The purpose of a
system is what it does. And what this
system does is help you write valuable
nonfiction. So, to understand value, it
helps to remember something that Elon
Musk said. A successful business is one
whose outputs are more valuable than its
inputs. And that's exactly what this
system does. It converts inputs into
valuable outputs. So, the outputs are
the content that you create, whether
it's essays, newsletters, scripts,
whatever it is you're working on. But,
what are the inputs? And what's inside
the machine that adds value to them?
Well, at a high level, the system has
two zones. So, there's inside the vault
and outside the vault. Now, outside the
vault is basically just life and culture
flowing through you. It's the raw
material that we bring and churn into
valuable outputs, extracting resources
from life and processing them into forms
that your audience actually enjoys
consuming. So, the goal here is to
capture everything that you think could
be valuable to your thinking. And then
we process it through the system, and
what you'll be left with is a highly
concentrated idea that you can write
about on demand. And so, outside the
vault, there are essentially two streams
of input. The first is from culture, and
that's everything that you consume:
books, essays, podcasts, articles. These
all go into the sources folder, and you
save them there raw and unprocessed.
You're not analyzing them in the sources
folder, you're just collecting them
there. And Obsidian actually does have a
great feature, a great add-on that you
can use to save something that you might
um find valuable later. So, let's say
for example, you found an essay that you
wanted to save, you can just you know,
you can read it there on the website, or
you can just come up here to the
Obsidian Clipper, and it formats
everything perfectly into markdown for
you, and will save it right into your
sources folder.
So, you allow that, and then you get
just a totally raw, unprocessed
um essay that you can come back to later
if you so choose. And the second stream
of input is what I call life. Now, these
could be conversations, dreams,
thoughts, experiences. Well, so let's
say you had a conversation with a
friend, and now you're walking away, you
want to bring it in and think about it a
little bit more. So, what you can do
here is pull out your phone, do a voice
recording, and then run that transcript
through AI to clean it up, and save it
into your vault as a fleeting note,
which we'll talk about a little bit more
in a second. But, note we have a folder
here called fleeting notes. That's where
sources from life go. Now, as I
mentioned, one thing that I highly
recommend bringing into this system are
your dreams. It's so helpful to your
writing to have a dream log. Freud said
that dreams are the royal road to your
unconscious, and I have found that to be
true. The unconscious is the source of
your creativity, the source of your
vision. So, the more that you can
harness this and learn to understand the
language of your unconscious, the more
it's going to color the outputs and give
your writing what we call a unique
style. And so, how do you use this
system once you've brought these things
in? Well, everything starts with a daily
note. So, here is a template that I run
every day. I just click on the day and
it pulls up a blank template. I've been
writing a little bit today, and so it's
filled out. But, on this template, there
are essentially two things. One, there's
a function that pulls in all the notes
that I've written or edited today. It
just searches the date function and
indexes them here. And the second one is
uh
to-do list for the day. I'm going to
list two or three high-leverage
activities that I want to achieve that
day with links to the relevant files.
Now, how do you choose what to work on
today? Well, I also have a weekly note
that we'll talk about in a moment, but
that's basically how I choose my daily
to-do list. Every week, I make a weekly
review, which we'll talk about
momentarily, and then I itemize some
some things I want to accomplish that
week. And so, when I'm making my daily
note, I just look at the weekly note and
I pull two or three high-leverage
activities from that weekly note. But,
essentially, this is where the entire
system begins with the daily note. And
the great thing about using these daily
notes is that you're left with a
calendar where you can just go back
months or years and and find out what it
was you were working on on any given
day. I've been doing this for many
years, and so now I can just click back
months and even years ago to see what I
was working on and what I was thinking
about. And because in this I'm
integrating not only the the kind of
projects that I'm working on, but also
my dreams and my journal and everything,
it's a really rich source to trace the
development of your thinking. And that
gets supercharged when we add AI to it.
But, before we talk about AI, I need to
show you what happens to the inputs when
we pull them through the daily note and
into the system. Well, whenever the
inputs come into the system, they go
into three kinds of notes. Each one is
like a refinement of the last one. So,
let me show you how this works with a
real example. So, last week I saw a
tweet from Dan Koe, who said something
to the effect of, "If you don't write,
you can't think." And I saw that tweet
and I thought, "This might be taking it
a little bit too far." And that really
puzzled me because I've been arguing
quite strongly about this idea that, you
know, writing is thinking. So, I
thought, "What's going on here?" Like, I
had an intuition that Dan was wrong, but
I hadn't yet sketched out my argument.
So, going back to the system, I had an
experience, or call it a conversation on
Twitter. And so, what I did is I wrote
about it. I wrote about that experience
in a fleeting note. Just in an ugly,
unprocessed kind of way, I jotted down
whatever it was I was thinking about it.
And the great thing about these fleeting
notes is that I have a function now, I
can do it right now. I have a function
that automatically generates a numeric
ID. So, it gives the year, the month,
the day, and even the time. So, I can
generate these, you know, one of these
every second. And it gives it a unique
number. And that's great because it
doesn't make you think about like,
"What's the title of this note?" And so,
it allows you to think about them in a
lot less of a structured way. So, I just
create one of these notes. I I hammer
out whatever I think, and then it'll
appear right here in my
um my daily my daily note index. And so,
the purpose of this note is just to
catch the experience without any
friction. And it gets saved there as a
fleeting note. But, as I was writing
about it, I remembered an essay, a
source, that I had read months ago,
which was an essay by Cormac McCarthy
called The Kekule Problem. Now, this is
an essay where McCarthy is trying to
understand why so many problems in
science and mathematics are solved in
dreams. The author basically wanted to
know why mathematicians and scientists
would often work on a problem for
months, go to sleep, and then find the
solution arriving as a riddle in a
dream. And the reason that it connected
to this exchange that I had with Dan Coe
is that his answer involved the
relationship between the unconscious and
language. And he says at one point in
this essay, quite confidently, that we
don't use language to think. Yeah, here
it is. He says, "But if you believe that
you actually use language in the solving
of problems, I wish that you would write
to me and tell me how you go about it."
Which is hilarious. He wants you to use
language to explain how you go about
using language to solve problems. So,
that's a hilarious joke, but I
remembered that line and it I saw some
connection to this exchange that I had
with Dan Coe. So, now I've got an open
loop. Like, I'm thinking about this
problem. If If McCarthy is right and we
don't use language to think, then what
does it mean to say writing is thinking?
And so, I pulled up that essay, which I
had saved in my sources folder, and I
opened up alongside of it a literature
note. So, a literature note is a lot
like marginalia. It's not highlights,
you know, there's um a popular
integration that people use with their
Kindle called a Readwise, which
basically just pulls in all of your
highlights unprocessed, but I really
don't find that helpful because I find
quotes on their own are not valuable.
They're only valuable insofar as they
prompt you to think. So, a literature
note, by contrast, is kind of like a
record of your dialogue with the text.
So, here's my literature note for that
essay of Cormac McCarthy's, where I
save, you know, the quote that prompted
me to think, and just jot down a little
note that I think alongside of it. And
notice that a lot of them are not
hyperlinked, so I'm not going to use a
lot of these, but this is a record of my
dialogue with the text. And so the goal
here is not to summarize the entire
article, it's not to write a thesis on
it, it's not to write a review of it and
publish that. The goal of a literature
note is just to talk back to the text.
And so a professor once told me that if
you want to read actively, all you need
to do is ask, "Where are things the same
and where are they different?" And so
that's basically what I do whenever I'm
consuming any of this media. I'm going
through it and I've got that question
running in the background. So there I
went through this essay, and as I was
just making this commentary, I was
asking myself that question. "Where are
things the same as this idea writing as
thinking, where are they different?" And
so this triggered all of my own ideas
from the text. And so as you note, you
know, there are many notes here and a
lot of them are interesting, but they
remain unprocessed. They're not relevant
to my thinking right now. The ones that
are highlighted are the ones that I've
converted into my own notes, and that is
the third kind of note, which is a
permanent note. And so if a fleeting
note is like a scrap of paper and a
literature note is like marginalia, the
things that you scribble on the margins
of your book, then a permanent note is
an atomic idea. It's an idea. Okay, this
folder, permanent notes, is what some
people might call a second brain. So the
goal is to write down a single
self-contained idea in your own words
with a link to the source and a link to
another note that's already in the
system. So if we go to permanent notes,
okay, so here's a note that I created
from that Cormac McCarthy essay. It has
a link to the source and the idea is
written up here in my own words, and I
also link it to another note in the
vault. I actually that note is not an
idea, but it's a question, and I think
that's a perfectly valid use of
permanent notes. It's a question that
I'm developing.
So, the idea here is that we don't think
with language. Language is an
unconscious process, and that links back
to this note, which is is language used
to think? And so, essentially this note
is starting a train which says no,
language is not used to think. Now,
later I might find a good argument for
how language is used to think, and that
would become 3.1A2.
I'll talk a little bit more about these
numbers in just a second, but the point
here is just to see how these three
types of notes are distinct from each
other. The permanent notes represent the
kind of most refined version of your
thinking, and they link to other notes
importantly. So, it really does become a
kind of
web that's growing here. As you can see,
you start to get these links and webs of
your notes as you link them together.
And so, the goal with these permanent
notes is to write down a single
self-contained idea in your own words
with a link to the source and a link to
a note that's already in the system. So,
I had the idea writing is thinking. And
now, I have a new idea, which is that we
do not use language to do our thinking.
So, when I brought that note into the
permanent notes folder, I looked for a
note to link it to because I wanted
those two ideas to talk to each other.
And that's the purpose of the
alphanumeric ID, which is not to create
a rigid hierarchy, but to make sure that
no note is orphaned. Every new leaf of
knowledge needs to attach to the tree
somewhere. And this is actually
something else that Elon Musk said,
whenever he was asked how he learns
difficult things so quickly and so
thoroughly. He said, "It's important to
view knowledge as a semantic tree. You
need to see how the leaves connect to
the big branches." The structure that
emerges through these connections is not
a strict hierarchy. It's more like a
rhizome. It's really messy, associative,
organic, but it starts to represent the
webs and connections of your thinking.
All these red notes are permanent notes.
Now, once these permanent notes start to
accumulate, patterns start to emerge on
their own. And so, for example, just
recently I was processing a podcast
conversation between a scientist and a
Lacanian psychoanalyst, which is an
unusual pairing since scientists don't
usually have much patience for
humanistic thinkers like Lacan. But, one
of the first things the psychoanalyst
said was that Lacan doesn't reject the
idea of truth. He grounds truth in what
he calls the truth of desire. And so, I
turned that idea into a permanent note,
not because I necessarily believe it.
You know, permanent notes can be ideas
that you don't agree with or that you're
not sure about or they can even be
questions. I created this permanent note
because I thought it was interesting.
That's it. And then, a few days later, I
came across a tweet from David Deutsch,
who's a philosopher and a physicist. And
he was saying something quite similar.
He said that you couldn't determine
action based on long-term goals because
you might be making errors in the
present that you won't catch until much
farther down the line. So, instead, he
said, "You should pursue your desire in
the moment and then use long-term goals
as a way of critiquing it." And I
thought, "Huh, that's exactly what I was
just writing about." So, it's this
really strange connection between a
Lacanian psychoanalyst and a philosopher
physicist that surfaced through the
system. So, now I've got the same idea
being made by a Lacanian theorist of and
a physicist. And so, I started adding my
own value to it by noting where things
are the same and where they're
different. And so, once you process your
ideas from fleeting notes through
literature notes into permanent notes,
these start forming the kind of
framework that you use to understand the
world. And you're going to be really
surprised by what you notice start to
connecting to that framework. And so, by
now you might notice that most of this
system comes from the Zettelkasten
method. And I tried to build this many
times over the years, but it always felt
like a filing cabinet, never the living
system that it promised to be. But, this
all changed when I brought AI into it.
But, to be honest, I was quite reluctant
to incorporate AI into this because I
really don't like AI coming in to do the
thinking for us. So, the key principle
here is that I wanted AI to work on my
thinking instead of doing it. So, more
practically, I didn't want AI to be
processing my inputs. I didn't want it
to be summarizing articles or telling me
what the main ideas are or pointing out
connections between my notes. I wanted
that thinking to be mine. But, one
problem with this original Zettelkasten
method is that on any given week, you
might be writing about all kinds of
different unconnected ideas. In my case,
I was writing about a Lacanian
philosopher and then reading a study
about sociology and then taking notes
about how to use my camera. Very
different territories. And so, by the
end of the week, I'd often forgotten
what I was writing about on Monday. So,
I wanted a way to see the macro patterns
across my thinking over time. And so, I
set up three AI agents to run weekly.
They all have access to my human layer.
Most of them only have access to my The
purple ones down here only have access
to the permanent notes folder.
Um this layer has access to the entire
vault. I say they're on different layers
because they cannot rewrite, delete, or
touch these. They can only read them.
So, what are these three AI agents?
Well, the first one is the keyword
index. So, you know how you can open the
back of a nonfiction book and just scan
the index in the back and then jump to a
given topic and read a few pages on it.
Well, what if you could do that for your
entire second brain? That's what this AI
agent does. It scans all of my personal
notes and identifies major themes and
surfaces connections across the vault.
So, I may be writing about language and
the unconscious on one side of the graph
and then writing and cognition on the
other. Well, this AI might notice
patterns between them and then it'll
create a higher-order link. And so, this
keyword index is really a source of
serendipity. Like, I can just browse
through all the index and jump back into
old threads that I forgot I wrote about.
Now, for the second AI agent, what if
you had a Wikipedia site just for your
second brain? Well, that's what this AI
agent does using two kinds of notes. Hub
notes are like maps of all the notes
that I've created on a given topic
organized into headings. They allow me
to scan the major trains of thought that
I've written about. And now, structure
notes are more like Wikipedia pages.
These give a narrative synthesis on any
topic built entirely from my permanent
notes. Now, all these notes are
generated and updated weekly and both
will flag gaps and underdeveloped areas,
open questions that I've left
unanswered, links that I haven't
followed up on, and areas that are
underdeveloped. Now, the third and final
AI agent is the weekly review. This runs
every Sunday morning. It goes through
all the notes in my human layer,
including the sources, fleeting notes,
literature notes, and permanent notes,
and manuscripts. And it gives me a
summary. That is, tasks that I've
completed, patterns that are starting to
appear in my dreams, themes from my
fleeting notes, key ideas from
literature and permanent notes. And it
compares what I did last week against my
quarterly goals and reminds me of the
remaining time in the quarter and then
suggests what I might focus on in the
coming week, which is really helpful
whenever I'm planning out the week
ahead. And now, because it includes
essentially my journal and my dreams,
I'm not going to show you that note.
It's a little bit personal, but
essentially every Sunday, I read this
note and then make my plan for the
coming week and then check that weekly
plan each morning when I'm on my daily
note and writing out my to-do list. But,
I have to say, the single most powerful
feature of this AI layer is the Q&A
function, which is a skill that lets me
talk to the entire vault. And so, to
show you how powerful this is, I'll give
you a quick example. So, recently I was
having a conversation with a friend
about South Korea's fertility rate. It's
one of the lowest in the world. He
argued that it was due to economic
factors. At least that's what everybody
says, "I can't afford children." But, I
pushed back. I said, "South Korea has
the lowest fertility rate in the world,
but the government subsidizes nearly
everything for children up to age five.
So, the economics argument doesn't
really hold." So, then I thought, "Why
are individuals still saying, "I can't
afford a child?"
And then the idea occurred to me
spontaneously that maybe this wasn't
really an individual decision. Something
is happening at the group level, an
emergent phenomena in the group that
trickles down into what feels like a
personal choice. It's kind of like how
individual ants make very simple
decisions at the micro level, but those
decisions produce macro level patterns
that serve the needs of the colony
perfectly, but which you could never
predict by watching a single ant. The
individual thinks they're in control,
but there's no central controller. It's
actually just the hive making the
decision. So, this was a new idea for
me. It's one that I didn't quite know
what I thought about it yet. And so, I
opened up the Q&A function, described
this idea, and asked, "Have I ever
thought about this before? Do I have any
notes that might help me think about it
or process it?" And so, when I asked
that question, the system surfaced a web
of
closely connected notes that I'd totally
forgotten about. And it gave me this
high-level summary of how they all
connect. And so, now I know what sources
and what fleeting notes to process next.
And this is so powerful because it gives
me exactly the sources and fleeting
notes that I can process and bring in to
my own permanent notes. These Q&A
outputs go in their own folder. They
don't modify my permanent notes or any
other part of the human vault. So, next
week, whenever these wiki agents are
going through my vault to process new
hub notes and structure notes, they
won't incorporate these AI outputs as
that would muddy the waters and dilute
my thinking. The AI is helping me
navigate through my vault, but it's not
rewriting it. This system works because
it keeps the thinking yours. And I have
to say a lot of people misunderstood the
promise that AI would help writers. They
thought it meant that AI would help them
write. But you don't want AI doing your
writing for you, and you don't want it
doing your thinking for you. What you
want is what this system delivers. AI as
a navigation layer over a knowledge
graph that you've built yourself. Now,
if you want to build a system like this,
I've created a free resource that you
can download along with a 10-day email
sequence that will walk you through it
step by step with templates and
instructions, starting with the daily
note, building the habit from fleeting
notes to literature notes to permanent
notes, and showing you how to use AI to
get the windmill turning on its own. But
if you want to learn how to write
without AI, then you need to watch this
video next because it's going to give
you my expert writing system, which is
designed to help writers do their own
thinking and convert that thinking into
value for readers. So be sure to go
check it out.